THE LATEST BAFFLING MOMENT OF
JOE BIDEN.
HERE WITH REACTION "BEYOND
BIDEN" IS IN BOOK STORES
EVERYWHERE, NEWT GINGRICH.
WHAT IS KAMALA HARRIS
ACCOMPLISHED?
SUPPOSED TO BE THE BORDER CZAR.
NEVER WENT TO THE ACTION WHERE
THE BORDER IS.
I HAVE A LONG LIST.
SHE HIRED A PR TEAM AND THEY HAD
A PHONEY VIDEO SESSION WITH
CHILD ACTORS.
DONE NOTHING AS BORDER CZAR.
THE WEIRD LAUGHING THAT IS
UNENDING.
GOES TO TRAVEL TO FRANCE.
COMES OUT WITH A PHONEY FRENCH
ACCENT AND DOESN'T RESOLVE THE
ISSUES INVOLVING AUSTRALIA.
WHERE IS THE SUCCESS, MR.
SPEAKER, BECAUSE I DON'T SEE IT?
>> THERE IS A WEBSITE THAT HAS
10 HOURS OF KAMALA HARRIS
LAUGHING.
>> Sean: 10 HOURS?
>> 10 HOURS.
IF YOU WANT TO PUNISH A FRIEND
MAKE THEM WATCH IT.
IT GIVES YOU A SIGN OF WHAT IS
HAPPENING TO HER.
THE LAUGHING VICE-PRESIDENT IS
NOT A GOOD THING IF THAT'S ONE
OF YOUR MOST FAMOUS
ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
I THINK SHE ACCOMPLISHED
SOMETHING VERY HISTORIC.
SHE GOT CNN HISTORICALLY THE
STRONGEST SUPPORT OF LIBERAL
DEMOCRATS TO RUN AN ENTIRE STORY
POINTING OUT THAT THE
PRESIDENT'S TEAM AND THE
VICE-PRESIDENT'S TEAM ARE
FIGHTING IN A FEROCIOUS WAY.
I HAVE NEVER SEEN CNN DO
ANYTHING THAT WOULD BE HARMFUL
TO JOE BIDEN.
THIS STORY WAS DEVASTATING.
IT STARTS WITH A SIMPLE FACT.
BIDEN IS AT 38% APPROVAL.
SHE IS 28% APPROVAL.
POWERFUL PEOPLE WAKE UP AND GO
IT CAN'T BE ME.
I YONDER WHO IS DOING?
-- WONDER WHO IS DOING THIS.
THE BIDEN PEOPLE SAY IT'S
HARRIS'S FAULT AND HARRIS'S
PEOPLE SAY IF ONLY HE WAS USING
HER CORRECTLY.
SHE HASN'T ACCOMPLISHED
ANYTHING.
IT'S AN EMBARRASSMENT.
BUT SHE IS WORKING WITH JOE
BIDEN WHO ACCOMPLISHED ALMOST
NOTHING.
JUST WATCHING HIM IN PUBLIC IN
A NON-SCRIPTED ENVIRONMENT, IT'S
FRIGHTENING FRANKLY.
TO THINK THIS THE
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF AND TO KNOW
THAT OUR OPPONENTS ARE ON THE
PLANET ARE WATCHING THE SAME TV
COVERAGE.
TO ME, THIS IS AN AMAZING MOMENT
FOR PROBABLY THE WORST
VICE-PRESIDENT IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
>> Sean: THEY HAVE THIS CONFLICK
THAT IS OBVIOUSLY GOING ON.
JOE AT 35% ON AVERAGE -- SHE IS
A LOW 28%.
I WOULD SAY AFGHANISTAN IS THE
REASON.
THE ECONOMY IS THE REASON.
MORE PEOPLE DEAD FROM COVID IN
2021 THAN 2020 IS THE REASON.
THE CHAOS AT THE BORDER.
INFLATION AND THE HIGH COST OF
ENERGY BECAUSE OF THEIR
POLICIES.
ALL OF THESE ISSUES PREVENTIBLE.
THEY COULD FIX IT IF THEY GO
BACK TO THE TRUMP POLICIES THAT
WORK.
WE KNOW THAT WON'T HAPPEN.
HOW DO THEY DIG THEMSELVES OUT
OF THIS HOLE IF THEY ARE NOT
WILLING TO CHANGE?
>> WELL, THERE IS NO EVIDENCE
THAT THEY WILL DIG THEMSELVES
OUT.
A MAJOR LIBERAL PUBLICATION
SHOWS THE REPUBLICANS AHEAD BY
10 POINTS IN THE BALLOT, THE
LARGEST LEAD IN 40 YEARS!
40 YEARS.
THAT POLL UNDERSTATES HOW BAD IT
IS.
IT OVER-SAMPLED DEMOCRATS AND
UNDER-SAMPLED REPUBLICANS.
THEY DON'T BELIEVE IN CLOSING
THE BORDER.
THEY DON'T BELIEVE IN STOPPING
CRIME.
IT WILL KEEP GOING UP.
THEY DON'T BELIEVE IN IT TAKING
ANY STEPS TO STOP INFLATION.
THE IDEA THAT BUTTIGIEG WHO HAS
NO EXPERIENCE IS GOING TO SOLVE
THE LOGISTICS PROBLEM IS CRAZY.
YOU WILL HAVE MORE AMERICANS
ANGRY.
EVERY DAY WHEN AMERICANS FILL UP
THEIR CAR OR TRUCK THEY GET
MADDER AT BIDEN AND HARRIS.
HARRIS SUFFERS MORE BECAUSE SHE
IS NOT AS WELL KNOWN AND HER
LAUGHING WHEN WE ARE SUFFERING
FURTHER ALIENATES HER FROM MOST
AMERICANS.
I THINK IT ENDED ANY CHANCE SHE
WILL BE PRESIDENT.
>> Sean: AND THE ENERGY
SECRETARY LAUGHING TOO.
>> JENNIFER WAS IMITATING KAMALA
HARRIS.
LEARN TO LAUGH.
>> Sean: IT'S NOT SO FUNNY.
THEY ARE DESPERATE.
THEY CAN STOP BEGGING OPEC AND
JUST ASK TEXAS, ALASKA, NORTH
DAKOTA AND OKLAHOMA.
THE BOOK I